yeah we boarded that highly suspect
warship bamba's pain it was an
infectious garbage scow so thanks for
the hot tip well you were closer yeah
and now we smell like garbage get a
reading on those tremors it was a mild
subduction under the African plate do we
have a visual how are we handling it net
it's a death quake under the ocean we
handle it by not handling it Carol are
we seeing here next month not likely
what you gonna get another haircut
listen fur face I'm covering a lot of
territory the things that are happening
on earth are happening everywhere
I'm thousands of planets yeah alright
it's a good point that's a good point so
you might not see me for a long time all
right uh well this channel is always
active so if anything goes sideways
anyone's making trouble where they
shouldn't comes through me okay
I don't think I want you looking at that
I'm not sure it pertains to you anymore
now this on the other hand has agent
Romanov's assessment of you read it
personality overview mr. stark displays
compulsive behavior in my own offense
that was last week prone to
self-destructive tendencies I was dying
I mean please and aren't we all
textbook narcissism agreed okay here it
is a recruitment assessment for Avenger
initiative iron man yes I got to think
about it read on Tony Stark not not
recommended that doesn't make any sense
how can you approve me but not approve
me I got a new ticker I'm trying to do
right by pepper I'm in a stable and fish
relationship which leads us to believe
that this juncture we don't like to use
you as a consultant
you can't afford me
then again I will waive my customary
retainer on exchange for a small favor
Rhodey and I are being honored in
Washington and we need a presenter see
what I can do
hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Black Panther2 Namor easter egg
video there been a couple Easter eggs
for Atlantis and Namor in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe going all the way
back to Iron Man 2 so we'll break it
down and I'll explain why black panther
2 is a Marvel phase 5 movie and not on
the Marvel phase 4 schedule we're doing
the Avengers end game and spider-man far
from home blu-ray giveaways all you have
to do to enter those is be a subscriber
and leave your best Namor Theory on the
video Namor is a perfect character you
can introduce as a black panther villain
the same way they introduced the mbaku
character in the Black Panther movie
first he shows up trying to fight the
throne away from Black Panther just
because their ideologies are so
different they're bitter enemies then
become allies I wouldn't call them
friends but they're definitely much more
friendly than they were before in mbaku
became king of Wakanda after both Sheree
in Black Panther got snapped so during
that scene Black Widow is asking a coy
way about an underwater earthquake off
the coast with all kinds of tremors and
aftershocks they didn't spend a whole
lot of time during the movie explaining
what happened in Wakanda during that
five-year time jump between the end of
Infinity Ward Santos's first snap in the
Avengers end game final battle mbaku
then became the strongest candidate to
take the throne as king of Wakanda
Okoye is still doing the same thing but
with 50% of wakandans around she has
more responsibilities on her hands but
both of them are staunch traditionalists
when it comes to Wakanda and culture in
society
remember mbaku hated the idea of
technology initially even though he may
have softened a little bit on it he's
still very stuck in his ways a coy way
is the same way too
she was all about protecting the history
of Wakanda black panther was making the
radical move at the end of the Black
Panther movie to open their borders and
start the outreach programs so you have
the perfect scenario with post snap
Wakanda going back to closing its
borders off again because of the tragedy
we need to take care of our own so
they're not doing quite as much outreach
as they would have done before being
more isolationist outside of
participating in these Avengers global
threat watch meetings but they're mostly
dealing with all the
craziness that's going on inside
wakanda's borders then you have this
giant underwater earthquake Atlantis is
partially or mostly destroyed after
they've already lost half of their
Atlantean population to being snapped
away in Namor not fully understanding
what happened between the Avengers and
Thanos to cause all of it so basically
you have the same thing happening to the
Atlanteans and Namor that happened to
Thor in the Asgardians first a whole
bunch of them get killed off then half
of those that survived gets snapped he
had the five-year time jump with them
trying to pick up the pieces now you
have the same thing happening in
Atlantis in Atlanteans already hates
surface dwellers and are even more
isolationist than Wakanda was Namor
lives through all these tragedies one of
the key differences between Namor and
other Marvel Cinematic Universe
characters is that he's very very
long-lived
so he's been key of Atlantis for more
than a thousand years and you have black
panther a brand-new king so you have the
idea of two kings going to war with each
other and wrestling with what it means
to be king but also dealing with all the
craziness that's happened between
Avengers infinity war and avengers
endgame then you have a koi over here
like you know there's an underwater
earthquake in the ocean who gives a crap
not our problem that is what caused a
lot of the problems that they dealt with
during the first black panther movie
yeah Black Panthers father and his
brother fighting each other his father
eventually kills his brother because he
stole the vibranium because he wanted to
help other people black panthers father
said that he felt like it was too risky
and they had no business getting
involved in the rest of the world's
problems and that leads them to their
killmonger plot so Namor just a
slam-dunk Black Panther villain in that
same vein some of the similar ideas from
the first black panther movie but just
on a much more massive scale dealing
with much more complex internal problems
Black Panthers storyline mirroring Namor's storyline as kings of their
respective nations and what it means to
be king in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so why is it Namor on the phase 4
schedule Black Panther made gangbusters
money how come they aren't rushing to
get the Black Panther sequel out Kevin
Feige said is mostly because Ryan
Coogler is still working on the script
they gave him four years to develop that
sequel and that took him a little while
to sign Ryan Coogler for the sequel they
didn't lock him down for a second movie
when he did the first Black Panther
movie so he's gonna get
crazy money now best rumor I've seen so
far is that it's gonna come out May
20-22 and be an early Marvel phase 5
film with guardians of the galaxy vol 3
it was such a big film they didn't want
to rush a bad sequel out when they could
take their time and make something way
better normally it would be like three
years but you have all this stuff with
Thor for being tail and Marvel phase
four so they just do wait a little bit
longer to release it but the other big
reason why they're waiting on it just a
little bit is because of Namor the
Atlanteans people with biologically
based powers very close to the ideas of
x-men and mutants and they're just not
quite there in the MCU yet Scarlet Witch
is just the tip of that iceberg because
there have been some of official Marvel
books that have described her as having
latent biological powers which is
basically them saying she's a mutant
without coming right out and saying that
she's a mutant but these books were
published before the Fox still went down
now Marvel can say anybody's a mutant
that they want to without any big legal
problems but they're using the Eternals
movie early Marvel phase four to explain
biological powers in the MCU and
typically Marvel introduces a big
concept like that in the movie before
doing movies that trade on similar plot
twists Doctor Strange is probably the
best example of that in the first Doctor
Strange movie they introduced the
concept of the multiverse and they
explained how magic in the supernatural
works in the MCU once they did the
supernatural as Kevin Feige explained
during the big Marvel phase 4 panel it
allowed them to do blade a vampire and
multiverse movies like Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness in that
you know next step on that road once
they establish all that they had the
foundation for their Avengers Secret
Wars multiverse movie amazing story
potential but you can't do something
like that until you explain a couple
other really big concepts in other
movies same thing with the x-men mutants Namor and people with biologically based
powers
that's why Fantastic Four x-men the
Blade movie Black Panther 2 are all
Marvel phase 5 movies not Marvel phase 4
right now there's a rumor that marble is
going to announce some of their Marvel
phase 5 movie dates at the d23 panel in
a few weeks if they do that of course
they'll do a video for it they're
probably gonna show off some footage
from the Marvel phase 4 movies too right
now these are the rumors for the early
Marvel phase 5 movie dates I mean it
makes
the Black Panther - and guardians of the
galaxy 3 would be some of the first
Marvel phase five movies because
guardians already has the cast and they
have a finished script but let me know
in the comments if Namor is the villain
of black panther - what do you want them
to do with the character after that
movie because I just don't see him
joining the Avengers anytime soon in
fun fact - right now the Aquaman sequel is coming out at the end of 2022 so will be
fun to see what happens when those film
go head-to-head or they decide to move
the release date of the Aquaman sequel
but I'm working on more Marvel phase
four videos and Eternals preview video
Fantastic Four and x-men videos if
there's any big questions or requests
that you guys have for videos just leave
them in the comments below
congratulations to the winner from my
last big spider-verse video Nick papel
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here to learn about the
live-action spider-man venom
spider-verse
TV shows they're making and click here
to learn about the Red Hulk deleted
scene from Avengers endgame thank you
so much for watching everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight!